so today i'm doing something crazy
i'm giving away a thousand pounds
cash to someone today i'm not just gonna
give it to them
i'm gonna ask them if they wanna buy it
they don't know what's in it
i'm gonna ask for 50 pounds in fact you
know what
i'm gonna put my car my 126
000 car included in the deal
true story if someone gives me 50 pounds
for this 50 pounds
i'm giving away my car i'm giving away 1
000 cash i've got a mystery box
would you like to buy it are you sure
i'm all asking is 10 pounds there could
be something really valuable inside
next i have a house now this house
is only worth about 60 000 pounds it's
actually cheaper than the car
however i'm going to give the house away
to somebody for free
this is the contract
to a house and
you can have the house
yeah now this one's not going to be
included in the mystery box
i'm going to tell them up front all they
need to do is sign for it
so today giving away a house giving away
a car and giving away
1 000 pounds in cash let's see how this
goes 1 000 pounds cash
with a keys to an autobiography range
rover
hey guys would you like to buy my
mystery box
excuse me bro would you like to buy my
mystery box
it could be very valuable
it could be very very valuable what do
you reckon yeah
i don't know actually like i have no
change next to me so don't worry don't
worry don't worry i'll have a
cob machine i am really
i don't know all i want is 50 pounds
for the surprise 50 pounds oh well
i don't know your mother you just check
your life
50 pounds that's it
but i'm really not sure 50 pounds you
got five seconds
all right your five seconds is up okay
you want to know what was inside
okay okay nah nah your decision is
finished there was a 1 000
cash can't leave it
[Laughter]
so how do you feel well i don't know
what to say my friend just told me to
buy it i'm gonna
buy like give you the half
hey bro have a great day oh sorry about
that one
hey guys would you like to buy my
mystery box
are you sure yeah are you sure there
could be something really valuable
inside
are you sure just just 25 pounds
10 pounds are you sure
look five pounds i'll give you the
mystery box
five pounds would you like it five
pounds
don't
all right
what's up my brother how you doing
brother would you like to buy my mystery
box five pounds
thanks five pounds sorry thanks
ah someone must take this i'm
literally offering this for five pounds
five pounds
excuse me ma'am i have a mystery box
i'm off i'm asking for five pounds would
you like it
are you sure okay thank you bye
ah you guys look fabulous
i've got a mystery box would you like to
buy it are you sure
i'm all asking is 10 pounds there could
be something really valuable inside
or not it could be incredible though
are you sure 100 okay would you like to
know what's in it
1 000 pounds and a range rover
five pounds
would anybody like the opportunity to
buy a mystery box
five pounds
[Laughter]
you want to see someone else buy it
listen we're doing a social experiment
just to see how much faith people have
you want to phone a friend
is that whatever we go
see there is something in it it could be
something really valuable
it could be really valuable do you want
it yes or no
no all right i'll show you what's in it
1 000 pounds cash
and a range rover you guys
missed out i would have i'm a
multi-millionaire i'm a youtuber and i'm
doing a social experiment
in all seriousness i genuinely would
have given it and someone today will
probably end up with a thousand pounds
yeah well hopefully guys hey thank you
so much for uh for allowing me to talk
to you at least
have a wonderful day do you mind if we
use the footage for youtube
all right appreciate you guys god bless
nope
hey you guys look like you're ready for
an opportunity
i have a mystery box five pounds is all
i want and it could be something really
valuable inside it
are you sure final answer all right
do you guys want a mystery box 50 pounds
are you sure it is very kind indeed
50 pounds it could be something really
valuable
you don't know what's in it
50 pounds okay how about 20 pounds
20 pounds
it could be like something really
valuable
it's what all right like this is what
you could have got
1 000 pounds cash and a range rover
i'm filming for youtube channel i'm a
multi-millionaire and i'm trying to give
away
some money and a range rover to somebody
who's prepared to have a little bit of
faith
you were finished you were finished
these guys over here were in the
background going do it do it and you you
couldn't even hear them
there's a prank as well we were
literally about to like
ship in some money no you weren't no you
weren't you're
all right we were you guys really really
i don't know about that
come on were you really gonna do it you
worked on the point about i thought it
was four quid each we could we could
have done that but you were thinking
about it we weren't thinking about it
but uh
what was what was holding you back what
was holding you back uh i suppose the
idea of just losing 20.
hey would you guys like to buy my
mystery box
are you sure but it could be something
really valuable
i think we've come right right now
but thank you anyway all right goodbye
now thank you
thank you well they were polite they
were polite they were nice
i'd like to buy my mystery box what is
it
you love a mystery box okay so youtube
it is i've been doing loads of youtube
videos on doing mystery boxes no way
okay well that's the coincidence it's
clearly meant to be you guys there's a
market you can hold it for a second
so here's hey here's the game subscribe
to elman
tick talk youtube go subscribe baby do
it okay so here's the mystery box
yes now all i'm asking for is a hundred
pounds absolutely [ __ ] not
absolutely not absolutely [ __ ] dope
why not a hundred quid
and if you haven't got the cash i have a
car machine
you're not that drunk we're not that
waved yet maybe you come back in like an
hour should we offer them should we
offer them the house instead then
should we offer them the house imagine
it was a house all right
give me give me give me give me give me
the uh i mean
imagine it could be the uk version of mr
beast
how about this then okay dude this sucks
girl man's got his
clipboard out this is
the contract to a house
and you can't have the house
seriously yeah right now
not april fool's absolutely april
suggested it was going to be your april
fool's video
wow this is how youtube works so it is
not not necessarily filmed on the right
day that's true that's true
i know you are i have a look at the
contract
and it's a house i don't have my glasses
one of my houses
and you can have it
[Laughter]
i got i can't afford to read it it's
gonna have one clock clause
this is is this proof that oh is this a
video about how contracts no one reads
them
it probably says have you seen that
thing on i'm like apple or something and
it said like
you have to give away your options the
buyer will pay the mortgage payments and
the mortgage
wait so it's not a free house it is you
you'll pay you'll pay a 100 pound option
fee and you have the option to buy in
three years for nothing
i don't really understand what's going
on so
i'm trying to figure out more trying to
work out what the video is here because
this is definitely not a house for us
i just want i'm trying to live your free
house please thank you i'm old and i'm
growing so i want a house
or you can get if you want you can just
buy a hundred pounds and have the
mystery box
the house or wow this could be more
viable than the house
i just don't understand what's going on
right i feel like having a dream
do you want to phone a friend and ask a
friend
how can we guarantee this we'd have to
properly read it george but i really
can't be asked why can i
i'm going to have you think you promised
me this is actually foreign the contract
is right there
okay so what do you want to do um
yeah i don't really understand do you
want to ring your uh do you want to ring
your solicitor
no if it was like without the camera i
think i'd believe it a bit more but like
i understand it's for youtube video so
that's why i'm just
i know how youtube works i do it so like
i understand that
nothing's ever as it seems valuable
[Music]
the contract is there if you're really
really careful you'll say
i've already can't be bothered with this
anymore not gonna lie this has been
lasting for so long
like can we just either find out what's
going on in the box it's quite good if
if he walks away and there's a house in
that box or a car to a ferrari
you can buy me one yourself
i mean i'll i'll give you a shot vodka
all right
it's been nice to meet you everybody
nice to meet you thank you very much
the box the box is
wait it has to ruin the mystery because
part of the payment is to find out
what's in it
so if i tell you what's in it then
you've got the mystery revealed and you
haven't paid anything
bye
okay so i offered a couple of ladies i
offered them a free house
i gave them the contract i told them
they could get their solicitors to read
over the contract
take as long as they wanted to make a
decision and they sent me away
and they weren't interested in the
mystery box
with literally
car keys for a range rover and
a thousand pounds hard cash
hey did you notice my twitch to put you
off a little bit
[Laughter]
how about free house
i just need your id and stuff and you
can have a free house
all right free house
free free house
i have the address of the house that is
my property
that's my property i own the total deeds
i was offering it for free
all i have to do is run the car read the
contract and sign it and no one
will sign it crazy
hey do you guys want to buy a house for
a pound
house for a pound five how about five
pounds
on card
bye
would you like a house it's like a house
they're like a house yeah i've got one
thank you would you like another one
no i'm good i'm good all right sorry all
right
yeah brother yeah would you would you
like to do a deal with me where we can
give you a house and things
ah
hey would you like to do a deal with me
where you can have a free house
excuse me would you like to do a deal
with me where you can have a free house
all right free house
hey would you like to do a deal with me
where you can get a free house
i'm asking people if they'd like to do a
deal with me where i give them a free
house
every single person is saying no
[Music]
wow